five ingredients I always have on hand
or olive oil good quality olive oil got
to be extra virgin cold-pressed really
good balsamic vinegar too usually from
Modena that's really crucial one thing I
learned from chefs is shallots kind of
make everything taste good it's amazing
I don't know how or why would they do
they're like the magic ingredient so
those to me are the kind of the Holy
Trinity that can I can whip up basically
anything and make it taste good with
those three things let's see what else
in my household well and it's not an
ingredient but it's my obsession right
now which is Reese's peanut butter cups
but that aside I have a problem we're
going to move on I would say a good
quality semolina pasta probably and
chicken because you can just use chicken
six thousand ways chicken is the most
searched term on epicurious and we
basically can't do enough recipes with
chickens so it is kind of the go-to you
know ingredient that everyone should
have in their house always and in fact I
have in my freezer i always have strips
of chicken that i can just pull off the
aluminum foil or pull out at the plastic
and just cook really fast because it
cooks so quickly what I love about
chicken is that its high protein low fat
and that it cooks so fast and that it's
so adaptable it's so versatile you know
it's like the little black dress you
just you have to have it so it's as
crucial
you